ja wir versuchen seit den letzten tagen
auch die ampel regierung davon zu
überzeugen dass wir jetzt dringend nicht
nur die frage der waffenlieferungen auf
den tisch legen und schauen dass wir
nicht nur mit diesen kleineren geräten
also anti panzer raketen dass die
ukraine aus gestartet werden sondern
dass man auch dass das schwere gerät und
so liefert das was jetzt
auflage ist das was jetzt nicht
gebraucht wird in deutschland oder in
den nächsten wochen aber wir brauchen
auch für die menschen vor ort die jetzt
seit sieben tagen gar nicht die keller
verlassen konnten weil der beschuss
ununterbrochen
liefen weil weil keine lebensmittel mehr
da sind wir haben gesehen diese bilder
die paul ronzheimer gerade heute gefilmt
hat in einem supermarkt in kiew das
heißt da müssen wir auch dringend ein
konzept erstellen nicht nur vielleicht
mit deutschen dabei deutschland könnte
da eine wichtige rolle spielen über
polen einen landweg damit die städte
versorgt werden kraftstoff fehlt
lebensmittel medizin also da sollte
koordiniert werden und ich glaube dass
die handball regierung aber auch die
bundesrepublik als solcher auch die
landesregierung den sind da habe ich in
der pflicht zuschauer zu helfen weil das
was er getan werden kann und heute hatte
ich eine schallt der mitte mit einem mit
ihrem kollegen axel müller aus
ravensburg und und da gab es schon ideen
also was kann man da machen vielleicht
pulver nahrung dass das schnell
geliefert werden kann damit die menschen
dann quasi mit dem was sie haben vor ort
versorgt werden können das heißt diese
idee liegt auf dem tisch und wir hoffen
dass die bundesregierung das die politik
dass die menschen auch dieses konzept
unterstützen denn es geht um dort unter
leben von von vielen zivilisten die
einfach unter beschuss leben müssen und
auszahlen müssen
inwiefern gerade wünschen angesprochen
christoph dein kollege was hältst du von
diesem versorgungs korridor wie schätzt
du es ein muss deutschland jetzt gerade
mithelfen vorgehen aber vielleicht auch
wie die ganzen europäischen ländern
zusammen das ist auch ein ganz wichtiger
punkt der ich auf der einen seite reden
wir über waffenlieferungen damit sich
das ukrainische volk verteidigen kann
aber auf der anderen seite müssen wir
natürlich auch diese humanitäre
katastrophe im blick haben und die
vielen unschuldigen zivilisten die davon
betroffen sind deswegen da gibt denke
ich gar nicht bei meinungen dass das
absolut unterstützenswert ist ich will
noch mal einen hinweis nur geben wir als
cdu zb in hamburg und auch viele
kollegen in ganz deutschland die
unterstützen solche initiativen und sind
auch in gesprächen mit der ukrainischen
diaspora vor ort und helfen wo man
helfen kann aber es ist häufig
sinnvoller dass auch über
hilfsorganisation zu machen die auch
eine große expertise haben als dass
jetzt jeder einzeln versucht irgendwie
ein paar sachen zu sammeln und die dann
vielleicht sogar selber irgendwo
hinzubringen sondern da wirklich auch
sehr stark auf die hilfsorganisation zu
setzen so erreichen dass an laut dass es
sieht ja das beispiel auf instagram die
menschen dann dort selber an die grenze
fahren um das zu tun ist da nicht
vielleicht bringt es mehr bei einer
hilfsorganisation am er ist das als
symbol nicht viel mehr was uns alle
miteinander vereinen geld nur das ende
das ist ja auch super man muss das auch
im einzelfall sich anschauen das kann
man jetzt schwer pauschal sagen aber es
gibt ja ganz viele in deutschland die
fragen sich wo kann ich helfen und wie
kann ich helfen und was mache ich am
besten und da gibt es unterschiedliche
möglichkeiten manchmal ist es
tatsächlich auch sinnvoll eine
geldspende zu tätigen weil man weiß dann
kommt das ganz schnell auch an und es
gibt auch profis die sich darum kümmern
dass das schnell zu den ukrainischen
menschen kommt als dass man jetzt selber
versucht so eine logistik aufzubauen ich
wollte nur einmal diesen hinweis geben
weil nicht viele tatsächlich auch aus
sehr guten motiven sagen ach ich
versuche jetzt selber das irgendwie
dahin zu bringen und das ist nicht immer
sinnvoll also die hilfsorganisation die
haben natürlich eine sehr große
expertise und erfahrung ich möchte gerne
drei fragen an sie stellen die sie ganz
einfach beantworten können ohne lange
erklärungen erstens sind sie dafür alle
energie importe aus russland zu beenden
zweitens wenn ich dafür alle russischen
banken aus trifft auszuschließen ja sehr
gut drittens sind sie dafür ein
handelsembargo gegen russland zu
verhängen wenn ich auch sehr dafür ich
glaube die die aktuellen maßnahmen die
reichen noch nicht aus und wir brauchen
dafür härtere beiden händen ja das ist
also ich bin genau wie sie der meinung
ist eben haben wir hart gestritten aber
hier hier teile ich ihre meinung
russland muss isoliert werden
zusagen muss noch viel stärker mit
sanktionen belastet werden wir brauchen
ein umfassendes handelsembargo weil nur
wenn russland das richtig spürt und
russland auch kaum mehr die möglichkeit
hat gas und öl irgendwo hin zu verkaufen
dann wird es dort zu einem umdenken
kommen und wenn wir sagen na ja wir
wollen doch noch ein bisschen gas
beziehen ein bisschen kohle und auch ein
bisschen öl dann ist das nicht
zielführend weil es immer noch dazu
führt dass russland genügend gelder im
staatshaushalt und dann auch gut
überleben kann während ist gleichzeitig
das ukrainische volk
wenig fahren sie gerne vorschläge man
hat endlich begonnen auch die yachten
von von superreichen hier in deutschland
zu beschlagnahmen das hätte man vor vier
jahren tun müssen und mein vorschlag ist
dass man sofort das was man hat in der
hand dass der deutsche staat verkauft
und dafür auch die menschen in der
ukraine und auch der wiederaufbau in der
ukraine schon heute beginnen sollte
finanziert werden kann das ist auch die
idee dass auch die in die konten der
zentralbahn großen sollte von anderen
banken das dass das muss alles
beschlagnahmt werden nicht nur jetzt
eingefroren oder es muss ein verfahren
gefunden werden damit man wirklich
diejenigen trifft und nicht nur trifft
sondern wirklich das geld von ihnen
wegnimmt und das geld sofort
wieder herum um den menschen die jetzt
da sind und leiden zu helfen henning ich
verstehe dass nun auch ich bin für
sanktionen gegenüber russland ganz klar
aber manchmal frage ich mich auch wir
haben uns zu lange aber das hat
deutschland getan von einem despoten
energietechnisch abhängig gemacht das
ist so herr beck hat heute er auch noch
mal gesagt dass wir energietechnisch
schon abhängig sind der ist mir dass
meine frage der natürlich auch an dich
wie wollen wir das jetzt so schnell
umsetzen also wir sagen wir
sanktionieren russland mit allem wie
machen wir das mit der energie in
deutschland gut es gibt ja auch die
möglichkeit auf lng terminal zu setzen
aus meiner sicht muss auch die kernkraft
eine option bleiben über das jahr hinaus
wir müssen auch über das thema kohle
noch mal reden und gucken dass wir mit
partnern wie den usa aber auch im
arabischen bereich versuchen da die eine
gas
das sagen und das ist in amerika ist es
problem ist wird sich der gaspreis dann
vermutlich verdoppeln weiß torwart aber
das ist das ist ein ganz entscheidender
habe ich noch mal darauf gaben was herr
jörges sagt natürlich werden ganz harte
sanktionen wird ein umfassendes
handelsembargo auch uns treffen und wir
werden das in den preisen merken aber es
ist doch nur glaubwürdig wenn wir nicht
sagen sobald es uns irgendwo auch selber
berührt lassen wir das und auch neue was
ihnen lieber weiter geld bekommen um das
ukrainische volk zu gelangen muss das
kann das kann nicht der ansatz sein aber
da muss und staat zahlen soll daher nach
der staat dann gucken wir gerade die
ärmeren und diejenigen die das wirklich
auch finanziell hart trifft unterstützt
da gibt es ja unterschiedliche
möglichkeiten mit einmalzahlung mit
steuersenkungen das hat man so komisch
der vergleich jetzt vielleicht erst mal
klingen mag aber wenn der korona krise
haben wir gezeigt wie man auch dann
hilfspakete schnüren kann aber ich finde
es völlig falsch wenn man sagt weil wir
hier selber keine einschränkungen spüren
wollen kaufen wir weiterhin russisches
öl oder russisches gas und finanzieren
damit ja putins krieg das kann nicht
sein können dort nur glaubwürdig können
doch nicht an diesem krieg auch noch
verdienen genau gehen wir von russland
subventionierte preise genießen das kann
doch wohl nicht im erlöse seien das
heißt die eu kommission hat ja schon
ausgerechnet vor einiger zeit dass die
deutschen lieferungen aus russland 55
prozent des gases 35 prozent des öls
sofort zu ersetzen wären aus anderen
quellen sofort zu höheren preisen aber
die müssen wir dann eben in kauf nehmen
und dann müssen wir sehen wie wir damit
umgehen und dann müssen wir leuten die
sich die höheren energiepreise nicht
leisten können einen ersatz geben
natürlich aus der staatskasse was immer
das dann bedeutet aber jedenfalls nur so
ist eine ethisch fundierte politik in
diesem krieg überhaupt denkbar und ohne
und ganz wichtig es muss nur einige
lebenslügen über bord geworfen werden
also wenn ich ihr habt mit den grünen ja
viele diskussionen gehabt die haben
gesagt die kernkraft geht gar nicht da
müssen wir raus aus kohle müssen wir
sofort raus auch das muss man
hinterfragen denn wir werden nur eine
grundlast kapazität in der
energiepolitik bekommen wenn wir auch
jenseits der erneuerbaren option haben
und deswegen glaube ich müssen wir auch
die debatte über kernkraft neu in
deutschland führen und wahrscheinlich
brauchen wir auch über dieses jahr hin
aus kernenergie in deutschland die runde
ist sich einig härteste sanktionen für
russland ich bin mir sicher dass du die
meinung auch teils deswegen kann ich
sagen die runde ist sich einig
oder siehst du das anders ist glaube ich
aber nicht ein das haben wir jetzt hier
schon mal gesagt und es war das zweite
leidenschaftliche plädoyers von herb los
für die kernenergie das würde jetzt auch
für den nutzen gestern gab es schon 1
ich glaube das hat deutschland in den
letzten jahren nicht gedacht dass man
das hier mal erleben wird in deutschen
talkshows